alors résultats du scrutin numéro 99 sur
l'amendement numéro 149 rectifier à
l'article 11 du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2011 nombre de votants 339 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 338 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 170 pour
l'adoption 185 contre 153 le sénat a
adopté et en conséquence la suite des
amendements discussion comme une tombe
amendement numéro 13
présentée par monsieur cazaux non
monsieur d'audignies vous avez la parole
nationale 1 présidente excusez moi cet
amendement donc se situe dans toute
cette réflexion de recherche de
nouvelles sources de financement pour la
sécurité sociale et nous paraît
important sinon essentiel que toutes les
formes de revenus soit mise à
contribution par est complètement
inacceptable que certains revenus soient
exonérés de l'effort de solidarité
nationale
on nous le savons un employeur peut
accorder à ses salariés certains d'entre
eux et souvent les mieux placés divers
émoluments en plus du salaire des formes
les sommes versées alors sous forme d'
épargne salariale intéressement
participation plans d'épargné entreprise
de stock options et d'actions gratuites
ont fortement grossi ces dernières
années entre 99 et 2007 elles ont
augmenté de 120%
leur part est passée de 6,1 pour cent la
rémunération totale des salariés à 8,1
pour cent
ceci n'est pas bien sûr sans incident
incidence pour les finances de la
sécurité sociale car ces empreintes mans
bénéficie d'importantes exemption en
2007 la cour des comptes a estimé le
manque à gagner pour la cité sociale à
8,2 milliards d'euros un forfait social
de 2 % a été institué dans la loi de
financement le cigre et sociale pour
2009 ce taux a été porté à 4 % pour
l'année 2010
proposé à 6 % pour cette année mais ce
forfait social ne concerne que les packs
salariale l'intéressement stock options
et actions gratuites en sont exclus le
présent amendement vise donc à
introduire des attributions de stock
options et d'actions gratuites dans
l'assiette du forfait social créé par
l'article 13 de la loi de finances pour
merci avis de la commission c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur dowd unis veut
appliquer la double peine aux stock
options et aux actions gratuites ce
n'est pas ce que souhaite la commission
des affaires sociales dans sa majorité
donc nous invitons nos collègues à
s'opposer à cet abonnement à vis du
gouvernement défavorable madame le
président très favorable y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote madame
david oui merci madame la présidente je
trouve quand même que sur un amendement
tel que celui qui vient nous présenter
yves daudigny on aurait pu avoir des
explications un peu plus fourni un peu
plus soutenue
parce qu'évidemment je sais bien que ces
attributions existe les stock options et
les
les actions gratuites etc ça existe et
en cela je suis bien d'accord avec vous
monsieur dériot nous pour notre part
nous les contestions et nous
préférerions qu'elle soit évidemment
intégré dans les salaires et que l'on
retrouve une vraie politique salariale
dans notre pays donc ces contributions
existe mais pour le moins pour le moins
il faudrait que c'est contributions
soient soumises à cotisations comme le
sont aujourd'hui les salaires pour pour
le moins il faudrait que ce soit taxé
pour que cela rentre dans les dents les
dans les caisses de l'état d'un point de
vue des ressources de notre protection
sociale
alors c'est vrai que dans celui ci
d'amendements nos collègues proposent à
ce que ses attributions soit sorti du
forfait social
mais là encore ce forfait social il est
toujours mis en oeuvre pour les mêmes
ceux qui gagnent le plus et là dedans en
incluant corps les stock options et les
attributions et les actions gratuites
donc vraiment monsieur le ministre vous
qui êtes à la recherche de ressources
nouvelles
vous qui êtes à la rue à la recherche de
mesures justes pour les comptes sociaux
et pour notre protection sociale
vous devriez vous pencher davantage sur
cette politique salariale de détourner
mise en oeuvre par grand nombre de nos
entreprises
bien évidemment tout cotées en bourse ou
au cac40 et qui elles n'ont absolument
pas eu de soucis pendant la crise
puisque je vous rappelle quand même que
ces entreprises pendant le premier
semestre 2010 ont connu une évolution de
85% de leurs de leurs dividendes
donc vraiment mes chers collègues je
trouve que là vous avez une attitude qui
est finalement irresponsable cette
attitude que vous nous reprochez et bien
aujourd'hui je pense que nous pouvons
vous l'a reproché une attitude
irresponsable car vous priver notre
protection sociale de ressources
pérennes importante et qu'il ne ferait
finalement pas beaucoup de défauts aux
personnes à qui on irait prendre ses
ressources
contrairement à ce que vous avez proposé
pendant le débat sur les retraites par
exemple mais aussi contrairement à ce
que vous nous proposez dans ce plfss
puisque vous allez augmenter diminuer en
tout cas les remboursements de
médicaments augmenter le forfait
journalier et c'est là vous allez vous
en prendre aux malades et aux assurés
sociaux donc vraiment je me demande
comment vous pouvez encore continuer à
appliquer cette politique et monsieur le
ministre je regrette votre peu d'intérêt
à nos débats de cet après-midi j'espère
que vous ferez preuve dans le reste de
la journée d'un peu plus d'attention à
ce que les parlementaires peuvent vous
expliquer monsieur le président fischer
que nous sommes là pour faire vivre les
préoccupations des françaises et des
français dans cette dans ce débat sur la
sécurité sociale et aujourd'hui il y a
véritablement et nous y avons déjà
insisté annie david vient de le rappeler
un des problèmes majeurs qui est la
préoccupation majeure des français c'est
l'effondrement du pouvoir d'achat et
notamment en matière de retraites mais
surtout de salaire et quand on regarde
les préoccupations des françaises et des
français
alors bien sûr si comme on le pense et
bien et la gauche devait revenir au
pouvoir en 2012 il y a le souci et nous
avons cette préoccupation qu'est ce que
voudraient les françaises et les
français et bien 78% dans un sondage qui
vient d'être fait 78% des français
expriment fortement l'idée qu'on ne peut
plus vivre avec les revenus actuels et
ça c'est un des points
je me suis évertué hier au soir à faire
la démonstration qu'en gelant les
salaires notamment des fonctionnaires
qu'en relevant au minimum les minima
sociaux
et bien il y avait de la part du
gouvernement une volonté de réduire les
dépenses publiques et à partir de là de
remettre en cause des dépenses publiques
et aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la moitié d'entre eux
vivent avec moins de 15 150 euros par
mois et 30 % avec moins de 13 100 euros
et la crise donc qui a été vécue en 2008
2009 mais qui est encore vivement
ressentie par nos compatriotes et bien
la crise rend encore plus urgente la
hausse du pouvoir d'achat
95 % des électeurs de gauche ils sont
favorables mais ce que j'ai retenu moi
c'est que 58% aussi des électeurs de
droite ils sont favorables
comme quoi je crois qu'il faut que nous
soyons une caisse de résonance on
conçoit de ce que ted hémicycle où ici
mais vraiment de la préoccupation est
aujourd'hui la préoccupation des
françaises et des français
c'est ça et toutes les politiques qui
sont mises en oeuvre dans l'union
européenne tente et font une pression
considérable et bien sûr notamment les
masses salariales sur les retraites et
on voit bien ce qui se passe en espagne
etc etc etc et plus particulièrement en
grande bretagne avec une réduction
drastique des dépenses publiques
merci ma présidente merci monsieur le
président à d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
si monsieur daudigny merci à madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous avons à travers
cette courte discussion
l'illustration de ce qui nous sépare de
la position du gouvernement et de la
majorité des déficits sociaux à bissau
tout le monde peut en prendre
connaissance les reconnaître nous avons
dit quelquefois qu'ils étaient bien sûr
subi personne ne nie les effets de la
crise mais aussi pour partie quelquefois
entretenu sinon voulu voulu en effet
parce que l'effort demandé à nos
concitoyens pour les combler
progressivement ne peut et ne pourra
être acceptée que si les justement
répartis or nous avons bien vu à travers
intervention à david habib précédemment
combien d'autres politiques de revenus
salariaux touchées en france à l'absurde
alors si devons continuer ainsi encore
avec des avantages hors du salaire pour
romandie il est pour le moins nécessaire
indispensable et juste que tous revenus
soient affectés de la même part de
cotisation sociale que le salaire lui
même alors il n'est pas question de
double peine
il est simplement question de justice il
ne faut pas parler sur ces affaires-là
en pourcentage il faut reparler en
valeur absolue voir quels sont les
revenus réels voir quelle serait la
participation réelle en euros et on se
rendrait à leur compte que la mesure qui
est proposé est bien une mesure de
justice sociale et non pas de double
peine
merci donc je mets au voir l'amendement
numéro 13 qui est pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
l'article 11
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
il n'y en a pas je mets aux voix
l'article 11 qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté
nous abordons les amendements et
articles dont le gouvernement a demandé
l'examen au début de cet après-midi les
articles additionnels avant l'article 9
l'article 9 l'article additionnel après
l'article 9
l'article 12 bis et l'article 14 avant
l'article de neuf amendements numéro 103
présentée par monsieur jego présidente
tian des finances chez cela monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le présent
amendement a pour objectif d'élargir
l'assiette de la crds aux plus values
immobilières réalisées à l'occasion de
la vente de la résidence principale
j'ai initialement rédigé cet amendement
en prenant en compte le vote de
l'assemblée nationale qui assujettis aux
prélèvements sociaux est donc à la crds
les plus values immobilières résultant
de la vente d'une résidence secondaire
sans prise en compte de la durée de
détention
en effet à l'heure où le parlement
revient sur ses engagements pris envers
les générations futures
il est donc justifiée que l'ensemble des
revenus perçus par des générations
actuelles soient soumis à la crds avis
de la commission mais sous le rapportait
oui madame la présidente le celui de sa
collègue si on peut comprendre
l'objectif que s'est assigné fixé le
sénateur jean jacques jégou au nom de la
commission des finances reprenant sa une
initiative de nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale visant les
résidences secondaires
la commission des affaires sociales a
considéré que le dispositif était mis en
place par le grade de la loi organique
plus les mesures qui sont prévus dans le
cadre de la loi de finances on a subi
social suffisent dans l'immédiat mais
rien ne s'opposera à ce que nous
puissions réfléchir à la suggestion de
notre collègue jean jacques jégou pour
les années futures
mais pour le moment la commission
affaires sociales demande de monsieur
jego de bien vouloir retirer son
abonnement à défaut a émis un avis
défavorable à celui ci je pense pas
qu'il ait encore rectifier son
amendement monsieur n'est pas rectifier
votre bande voilà on va écouter monsieur
ministre sur les gouvernements
merci madame la présidente le
gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement pour deux ou trois raisons
que président je vous connais bien
d'abord sur le plan des techniques
assujettir la crds à des personnes
physiques qui ne sont pas résidents en
france paraît très difficile c'est ce
que porte l'une des références de votre
amendement
deuxièmement intel assujettissement
alourdirait les obligations déclaratives
des redevables sur des opérations
aujourd'hui exonérés pour un gain qui
demeurera une limite et de l'an 2 25
millions et enfin je me permets de
rappeler quand même la position du
gouvernement en la matière nous avons
proposé une augmentation de 0,2 points
de prélèvements sociaux sur l'ensemble
des revenus du capital pour financer le
maintien de la possibilité départ à 65
ans sans décote des mères de trois
enfants ou d'un enfant handicapé donc en
particulier sur ce type de revenus et
une augmentation de 3 points du taux
d'imposition des plus values
immobilières on ne peut pas donc dire
que le gouvernement n'a rien fait sur
ses revenus qui sont largement mis à
contribution dans le cadre notamment de
l'application et la déclinaison de la
réforme des retraites
oui monsieur jego la parole la
présidente ce ministre j'ai bien entendu
et je pars du principe qu'il va falloir
plutôt se concentrer sur les vrais
combats mais en moins c'est-à-dire ceux
qui suivent
néanmoins je pense qu'il faudra tout de
même y penser je pense que
lorsque l'on en obstant les problèmes
techniques que vous développez sur les
résidents étrangers
c'est vrai que c'est plus c'est plus
difficile bien que quand même on a
beaucoup de résidents de l'union
européenne qui résident dans les
résidences secondaires en france
mais ce sera quand même un signe pour
les générations futures que lorsque les
générations actuelles font des plus
values qu'il puisse participer à réduire
le déficit que nous avons dans nos dans
nos budgets sociaux
donc je retire cet amendement il est
retiré avant l'article 9 plusieurs
amendements quatre mamans discussion
commune
l'amendement numéro 44 présentée par
monsieur vasselle au nom de la
commission des affaires cela présente
semi sa collègue voilà un amendement
extrêmement important qui suscitera
peut-être des échanges entre le
gouvernement les rapporteurs et les
membres de la haute assemblée concernant
donc le financement de la cades est ce
pour faire face aux déficits que l'on a
transféré venant du régime de la
sécurité sociale et des quatre bans
alors peut-être un petit point
d'histoire mes collègues pour vous
compreniez bien
l'exercice auquel nous vous proposons de
de vous soumettre en acceptant de voter
cet amendement le gouvernement lorsqu'il
nous a présenté le texte de loi
organique la réforme de la loi organique
concernant la kadey ce a proposé que la
cades est ce au moment du transfert du
déficit des 130 milliards globo une
partie serait financé 32 milliards
seraient financés par une recette venant
de la taxation des compagnies
d'assurances générant une recette de 3,2
milliards d'euros
or nous nous sommes rendus compte assez
rapidement que cette recette ne serait
ni dynamique ni père est dans le temps
et nous avions introduit dans la réforme
de la loi organique une dispositions
tendant à obliger le gouvernement au
moment de la présentation de la loi de
financement de faire le point sur
l'insuffisance des recettes et de la
compenser par des recettes nouvelles qui
seraient affectées à la cades s c'est un
dispositif de tuyaux riz qui n'était pas
simple et qui compliquait la lisibilité
donc du dispositif l'assemblée nationale
par la voix du président de la
commission des lois s'est opposé à cette
idée de transfert sur les générations
futures du poids de la dette notamment
en ce qui concerne l'allongement de la
durée de vie de la cades s est dans le
cadre donc des échanges qui ont lu à
l'assemblée nationale notre collègue
marie anne montchamp a déposé un
amendement en intégrant dans la loi
organique
le fait que les recettes qui devait
alimenter la cades elle devait être soit
la crds soit la csg soit les deux
éventuellement puisqu'il ya déjà de la
csg de la crds qui assure le financement
de la can est ce le gouvernement à
accepter cet amendement de marie-anne
montchamp qui était un amendement de
compromis c'est bien compris pour
satisfaire donc les récriminations de
notre collègue
le président de la commission des lois
conséquence de cela c'est que le
gouvernement nous propose dans la loi de
financement
que ce soit la csg qui alimente le
budget de la branche famille qu'ils
soient qui viennent alimenter donc la
cades est ce cela a pour conséquence
d'affaiblir la branche famille au niveau
de ses recettes
puisque le manque de dynamisme de ses
recettes que nous dénoncions pour la
cadette va et va être répercutée sur la
branche famille alors ceci est un peu
compliqué on aura l'occasion de reparler
de ce sujet lorsque nous abordons la
question du paquet fiscal et de la
compensation des allègements de charge
par la suppression du panier et le
transfert des recettes du panier aux
différentes branches donc je m'étends
pas sur ce point
mais la conséquence de cette disposition
ne nous a pas satisfaits c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons considéré que
pour par affaiblir la branche famille au
niveau de ses recettes
il valait mieux augmenter la crds ce
d'autant plus que l'augmentation ne
représente qu'une augmentation de 0 26
point puisque nous passons de 0 5 à 0 76
la crds al'avantage de représenter une
assiette large donc de faire supporter à
nos concitoyens une augmentation qui est
relativement modérée même si elle est
trop lourde qu'un parce que toute
augmentation pèse inévitablement sur le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens et
nous pensons que ce serait un moindre
mal pour nos concitoyens plutôt que
l'ensemble du dispositif parce que les 3
milliards 2 qui sont censés venir
alimenter la branche famille qui seront
financées par les compagnies
d'assurances par la mutualité française
par les fédérations d'assurances et par
la prévoyance oraux pour conséquence si
j'en crois les propos qui sont tenus par
le représentant de ces compagnies
d'assurances de provoquer une
augmentation des contrats responsables
dans la proportion de 8 à 10% et nous
considérons que l'impact auprès de nos
concitoyens des 8 à 10% serait beaucoup
plus élevé que l'impact des 0,26 en plus
je termine par ajouté qu'en faisant
cette proposition la commission des
affaires sociales est constante dans ses
propositions puisque déjà là des
précédentes nous avions proposé une
faible augmentation de la crds pour
reprendre déjà une partie de la dette
qui s'étaient constitués en considérant
que ce n'était pas une bonne chose de
reporter toujours au lendemain des
décisions qui étaient à prendre et qui
ont inévitablement à un moment donné un
coup la preuve en est c'est que le
l'impact sera plus douloureux
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'aurait été si
nous l'avions fait l'année dernière le
gouvernement avait fait valoir que nous
étions en période de crise et qu'en
période de crise il ne fallait pas
impacter le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens ce que nous avons fini par
comprendre départ acceptées mais
aujourd'hui la solution qui vous est
proposé de ne paraît pas satisfaisante
d'où la proposition d'amendements que je
vous fais au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales je note d'ailleurs que
jean jacques jégou au nom de la
commission des finances va proposer un
amendement qui s'apparente à celui qui
pratiquement hypothéqué ensuite la
commission des affaires sociales que
notre collègue gilbert barbier propose
un moment un peu de la même nature mais
un niveau légèrement inférieur au nôtre
et que jean arthuis propose également un
amendement qui va dans ce même centre
dont kylie a dit pas quasi unanimité des
membres de la haute assemblée pour les
dans cette direction parce que nos
collègues du groupe communiste eux ont
une quelques nuances le propos voudrait
concentrer le prélèvement sur les
revenus du patrimoine et non pas sur
revenus du travail
voilà j'ai été un peu long sur ce sujet
mais c'est un point important dans ce
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui prépare donc l'avenir et qui
est déterminant sur l'attitude que nous
aurons adopter à l'avenir en ce qui
concerne le financement de la dette qui
est transféré à la cades est -ce qui
pourrait malheureusement être à nouveau
le cas dans les années futures si on n'a
pas réussi à contenir les déficits du
régime que du régime de la sécurité
sociale
nous avons un sous-amendement 558
rectifier c'est monsieur fisher qui le
présente
oui alors ce sous-amendement d'ailleurs
monsieur le rapporteur vient d'y faire
allusion
nous entendons limiter la hausse de la
crds à celle à six sur le patrimoine
afin de ne pas pénaliser les revenus
issus du travail alors je dirais que la
proposition du rapporteur est une
proposition récurrentes qui revient
chaque année par isc cette année comme
l'an passé
notre collègue alain vasselle a déposé
un amendement tendant à augmenter la
crds
afin de permettre à kde est d'assurer le
remboursement des dettes qui lui seront
transférés notamment suite à l'adoption
de la loi organique relative à la
gestion de la dette sociale et la
proposition de relèvement de la crds
sa compagne est en général aussi d'une
inde un allongement de la durée de vie
de la cades s mais cette proposition
appelle de notre part deux observations
qui justifie le sous amendements que
nous avons déposés
tout d'abord une augmentation de la crds
et bien en augmentant celle ci le
sénateur vasselle fait la démonstration
qu'il est tout à fait possible
d'augmenter les prélèvements ce à quoi
se refuse le gouvernement et sa majorité
d'une manière je dirais hypocrite
puisque d'une manière hypocrite et bien
on tape dans les niches fiscales mais
surtout eh bien on augmente les impôts
les taxes et cetera
ca c nous y reviendrons et nous en
ferons la démonstration
or ma deuxième observation la taxe
qu'ils ont augmenté et parmi les moins
juste qui soit puisque la crds n'est pas
progressive et nous avons été un certain
nombre à travailler dans le fameux
groupe de travail qu'avait organisé
monsieur baroin où tout le monde de
vente est la crds comme ayant par une
augmentation relativement faible et bien
le pouvoir compte tenu de son assise
large très large et bien de ratisser
large et de rapporter beaucoup et je
regrette que d'ailleurs que notre
collègue et lors de son intervention
général écartés de manière aussi
lapidaire nos amendements de financement
car si une meilleure taxation des
éléments complémentaires aux salaires
stock options parachutes dorés
attribution gratuite d'actions
intéressement et participation
ce que vient de dénoncer annie davy ne
règle pas le problème de sous
financement de la sécurité sociale
eh bien il en est de même de la
proposition qu'ils formulent à travers
son amendement numéro 44
or il y contribue et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle la cour des comptes
propose dans son rapport annuel de taxer
ces éléments à 19%
c'est à dire juste 1% de moins que les
salaires afin de ne pas décourager les
employeurs mais très proche du taux
normal afin d'éviter les anomalies que
nous connaissons à l'heure actuelle donc
la question du financement de la
sécurité sociale est une question
complexe
nous considérons qu'il ne faut pas jeter
l'anathème sur aucune proposition et
c'est donc de matières totalement
ouverte que nous abordons cet amendement
et nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
plus précisément donc ne pas appliquer
la hausse de la crds aux revenus issus
du travail
merci
l'amendement 102
mais chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jego pour nous présenter
l'amendement 102 je vous remercie madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mais
chaque collecte comme je voulais indiqué
lors de mon intervention lundi dernier
les modalités de gestion de la dette
sociale proposée constitue pour moi un
point de désaccord majeur et je vous
demande mes chers collègues sur tous ces
bancs de bien écouter car souvent c'est
un peu technique comme le disait mon
excellent rapporteur la vasselle et on a
le sentiment que les choses ne sont pas
bien connus de part et d'autre alors ces
techniques certes mais quand on écoute
bien la démonstration on comprend tout
de même l'importance majeure de notre
situation
le refinancement des 130 milliards
d'euros qui nous est proposé de
transmettre à la cades s entre 2011 et
2018 soit l'équivalent je le répète de
10 mois de dépenses d'assurance-maladie
s'appuie suite au vote de l'assemblée
nationale sur le transfert de 0,28 point
de csg actuellement affectée à la caisse
nationale d'allocations familiales
celle ci se verrait en contrepartie
affecté le panier de recettes
initialement constituée pour la cadette
mais très critiquée par nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale puisque compte
tenu de la chute de ses recettes
très vite d'ailleurs dès 2013 il n'ya
plus le compte la chute de plus d'un
tiers de son rendement et est est assez
est assez important or ni la proposition
initiale du gouvernement ni la
proposition retenue par l'assemblée
nationale et l'amendement montchamp ne
sont satisfaisantes
la première en affectant la cades est ce
un panier que je qualifierais de persée
ne garantit pas à cette dernière des
ressources suffisamment pérenne et
dynamique
la seconde en privilégiant la qualité
des ressources de la caisse fragilise le
financement de la cnaf qui dès 2013
enregistrera une diminution sensible de
ses recettes sans qu'aucune alors que la
cades est là possèdent sans qu'aucune
clause de garantie ne soit actuellement
prévus et on a vu notre collègue
hier andré lardeux expliquer les
difficultés de la branche famille outre
les difficultés de financement de la
branche famille
le transfert de csg n'est pas
satisfaisant car il n'y monsieur
ministre la spécificité de la crds
cette dernière bien qu'elles soient
considérées comme une imposition de
toute nature au titre de la technique
fiscale revêt en fait une dimension
toute particulière elle ne finance pas
des dépenses de fonctionnement actuel
encore moins des dépenses d'avenir
elle constitue le remboursement de
dépenses de protection sociale effectué
mon raisonnement est sans doute
simpliste monsieur le ministre vous avez
fait cette qualification lors de votre
réponse mais votre position de principe
de ne pas augmenter les prélèvements
obligatoires conduit donc aggravé les
déséquilibres financiers des régimes
obligatoires de base par la mise en
place de schémas financiers acrobatique
j'attendais d'ailleurs un jeu voilà je
vous donne d'ailleurs ce ce montage que
j'ai présenté ce n'est quand même pas
très simple vous avez vu plus compliqué
mais je vous invite pour montrer ce
qu'ils nous obligent à faire sans aucune
garantie
alors donc où le parlement vient
d'accepter non seulement d'utiliser de
manière anticipée le fonds de réserve
des retraites mais aussi de prolonger de
quatre années la durée de vie de la
cades est ce qui je rappelle mes chers
collègues
si tout s'était bien passé devait se
terminer le 31 décembre 2009
au départ nous en sommes à 2025 et on
parle de préserver les générations
futures
oui on dépend tout à fait monsieur le
ministre nous sommes en train de payer
des feuilles de maladie qui ont été
dépensés en 1997
c'est quand même je crois qu'il faut
vous en rendiez compte quand même à
l'heure où le parlement vient donc de
reporter sur les générations futures une
charge qu'il souhaiterait encore
pleinement assurée il ya cinq ans il ne
me semble pas responsable d'accepter le
schéma de refinancement de la dette qui
nous est proposé ceci d'autant plus que
le transfert de dette envisagé par le
projet de loi de financement
on est loin de constituer en plus un
solde de tout compte
vous allez voir que dès l'année
prochaine or constitue quand même encore
quelques 30 milliards de dettes
supplémentaires sauf à vouloir mes chers
collègues je vous demande de porter une
attention toute particulière
ce n'est pas idéologique c'est
franchement une alerte que je voudrais
vous vous témoigner cet après midi sans
sauf à vouloir nous départir de nos
responsabilités morales et financières à
l'égard des générations futures
je vous propose donc de voter à l'instar
de la commission des affaires sociales
une augmentation de la crds de 0,26
point afin de préserver aussi bien le
financement de la cades est ce que celui
de la branche famille
l'alternative ne doit pas être de
choisir entre la fragilisation de la cad
s ou celle de la cnaf
c'est en plus ses joues le re joue le
prouverai tout à l'heure un effort
raisonnable et justifiée
merci le 404 un monsieur arthuis
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole
madame la présidente
g à titre personnel une part de
responsabilité dans l'institution de la
cades est ce les années 91 92 93 93 qui
avait été la première récession depuis
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
avait mis à rude épreuve les finances
sociales et nous avions une dette
sociale et à l'époque
considérant que c'était une situation
tout à fait exceptionnelle
on avait repris le modèle de la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette de la sncf
qu'un gouvernement précédent avait logé
dans un dans un satellite qui nous a
posé problème quelques années plus tard
pensant qu'il n'y aurait plus jamais de
déficit de la sécurité sociale peut-on
financer par emprunt
les dettes de la sécurité sociale
certainement pas donc nous pensions que
la caddel saurait une vie éphémère et
que cette crds suffirait
au terme de quelques années à amortir
cette dette
malheureusement le déficit est devenue
chronique et depuis 96 et gouvernements
successifs ont logé à la kadey ce champ
30 milliards d'euros
et comme ça ne suffit pas alors
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une dette
considérable de l'acoss non ce n'est pas
la vocation que de porter une dette
il va falloir logé au titre des années
2009 2010 et 2011 68 milliards
supplémentaires et comme la réforme des
retraites que nous venons de voter va
générer au moins 62 milliards sur la
base d'hypothèses macroéconomiques
optimiste entre 2012 et 2018
il faudra loger à nouveau 130 milliards
sur les 130 premiers milliards la cades
est a pu amortir à ce jour que 46
milliards et il reste 84 milliards et on
va ajouter 130 milliards supplémentaires
quelle idée nous faisons nous de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle en
reportant ainsi devant nous une montagne
de dettes comme s'il s'agissait d'une
dette perpétuelle
nous avons le devoir d' enrayer ce
processus alors le gouvernement nous dit
mais je fais des efforts sans précédent
pour tenir la dépense publique oui c'est
vrai puisqu'on va ramener le déficit de
l'état de 152 milliards à 92 milliards
mais sur les 60 milliards de réduction
du déficit
35 milliards s'explique par le
non-renouvellement de l' emprunt pour
les investissements d'avenir
une douzaine de milliards pour la queue
du programme de relance qu'on ne reverra
pas en 2011 contrairement à 2010 et puis
quelques milliards supplémentaires donc
l'effort est bien modeste au lendemain
des conférences le déficit public on
nous disait qu'on allait baisser de 5%
les dépenses de fonctionnement de l'état
et les crédits d'intervention
force est de constater qu'on va les
réduire de 0 5 à 1%
donc nous avons les pires difficultés à
comprimer la dépense publique et donc
nous ne pouvons nous exonérer de
obligation de mettre en recouvrement un
supplément de cotisation
tel est l'objet de la crds enfin je
voudrais vous dire monsieur le ministre
que le tableau très très harmonieux que
vient de vous remettre monsieur gigou
n'est harmonieux que parce qu'il ya de
la couleur mais il est proprement
illisible incompréhensible et il n'y a
pas si longtemps le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré des textes au
motif qu'ils étaient incompréhensibles
et qu'ils étaient excessivement complexe
va venir un jour où cette organisation
de tuyauterie complexe va être censurée
par le conseil constitutionnel alors de
grâce ayons les chers collègues le
courage d'augmenter de 0 26 la
contribution au remboursement de la
dette sociale
nous sommes lucides soyons courageux
merci le 303 rectifié be s'est présentée
par monsieur barbier
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
voulons avoir une démonstration
brillante la part du rapporteur général
et le président de la commission des
finances sur ce problème de la dette
sociale que nous allons encore creusé le
par ce budget je crois comme le
rappelait que les gars tu es il n'est
pas je les dis dans mon intervention
l'excution général ce n'est pas
raisonnable de financer des frais de
fonctionnement avec de l'emprunt il faut
absolument essayer de sortir le plus
possible de cette disposition
je crois que ce qui est présenté dans
nos amendements précédent sur le taux de
0 26 % d'augmentation
eh bien ça serait une bonne chose de
pouvoir le retenir
je présente un amendement avec un taux
légèrement inférieur pour dire qu'il
faut quand même garantir à la cades est
ce une part de ressources pérennes par
le seul biais d'une ressource dynamique
par le biais de la crds c'est pour cela
que j'ai retenu le taux de 0 65 au lieu
le 2 0 60
c'est une partagent un petit peu la
poire en deux je pense que c'est un
effort qui peut être faits soient
forcément nu à le constituer j'ajoute un
élément important c'est que je souhaite
que cette augmentation si elle était
acceptée par le sénat soit 1 sortie du
bouclier fiscal ce qui m'apparaît une
chose extrêmement équitable vis-à-vis de
nos concitoyens et ça donnera un peu
plus de dynamisme cette recette avis de
la commission sur le sous-amendement 550
vite rectifié et sur le 303 rectifié
beast sur le sous-amendement de monsieur
fisher nous n'avons pas considérer
souhaitable dessus monsieur fisher dans
ses propositions pensons que si nous
sollicitons une augmentation d'un csc
pour que elle reste assise sur la
totalité de l'assiette telle qu'elle
fonctionne depuis le départ ne se serait
pas mon avis de bonnes choses de
procéder à un décrochage entre l'un et
l'autre sur l'amendement de monsieur g
vous m'écoutez c'est un avis favorable
puisqu'il est identique à celui de la
commission sur l'amendement de jean
arthuis
ils étaient identiques aux amendements
de la commission et des affaires
sociales donc c'est également un avis
favorable mais le circuit dans l'exposé
de ses motifs a étendu la préoccupation
qui étaient les siennes à celui du
déficit du budget de l'état et reçues
souvent n'est plus à rappeler ici mais
circle est que si on dénonçait assez
régulièrement le déficit du musée la
sécurité sociale qui est presque une
fois et demie supérieure au budget
d'état il restait toujours dans des
proportions proportion qui était
beaucoup plus acceptable que celui du
budget de l'état qui était souvent trois
quatre cinq fois supérieur à celui du
budget les suivre et et social mais ce
n'était pas une raison pour ne rien
faire donc on est là pour assurer la
maîtrise des comptes publics dans son
ensemble que ce soit ceux du budget de
l'état où cela suive et et social donc
c'est un avis favorable à l'amendement
de monsieur arthuis quant à l'amendement
de notes
le collègue gilbert barbier il les
angles en deçà de ce que nous proposons
donc nous lui suggérons de retirer son
amendement au profit de celui de la
commission qui permet de régler une
bonne fois pour toutes si nous sommes
suivis en fait bonne fois pour toutes
pour les 130 milliards en question fall
les 68 milliards en question la
situation en sachant que de toute façon
nous allons voter une loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale encore avec un
déficit prévisionnel de plus de 20
milliards de plus de 20 milliards
d'euros
donc que nous retrouvons inévitablement
dans les années futures ne faudra bien
aussi que nous donnions nous réservions
un sort à ce déficit qui est en train de
se reconstituer
j'espère que la maîtrise des dépenses
tous permettra de l'atténuer le plus
rapidement possible merci à vis du
gouvernement
la présidente monsieur rapporteur
général monsieur présent la commission
des finances monsieur le président j'ai
gommé les messieurs bons nous sommes là
au coeur d'un débat qui est évidemment
un un poids important de l'architecturé
générale de la construction du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et qui nous ramène quelques
jours en arrière puisque nous sommes au
coeur du débat qui anime et de manière
assez vigoureuse
la haute assemblée l'assemblée nationale
et les professionnels concernant la
gestion de la dette sociale doit d'abord
remercié le président arthuis qui a
rappelé les vertus de la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale qui
est une structure vertueuse qui gère à
la fois les intérêts capital vous l'avez
dit vous-même monsieur le président ça
nous rappelle quelques souvenirs communs
nous étions ensemble au gouvernement
j'étais un modeste porte parole du
gouvernement vous étiez à l'épaule a
qu'au plan mais ce n'est in de se
dessinait déjà vos immenses
responsabilités à la tête de bercy pour
définir les contours de ce qui
permettrait à terme de gérer et le
capital et les intérêts de la prise en
compte de l'accumulation de déficits
s'agissant de la dette sociale
je tiens à trait sur le passé sans en
oublier les conséquences qui nous amène
aujourd'hui à discuter de cette question
je veux dire d'abord que la logique
initiale du gouvernement c'est une ligne
de conduite qui s'inspire de deux idées
très simple
la première le respect des engagements
nicolas sarkozy à l'époque candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
devenu président de la république de ne
pas augmenter les impôts et les
prélèvements obligatoires c'est de peu
d'importance pour vous c'est absolument
essentiel pour nous le respect des
engagements
le respect de la parole donnée la tenue
d'une ligne de conduite la définition
dans la durée d'un acte politique fort
qui incarne une politique c'est un
élément constitutif du regain de
confiance que les français auront
progressivement vis-à-vis des politiques
proposées par le gouvernement sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république le deuxième c'est que nous
sommes dans une situation où au
lendemain de la grande crise de 2008
2009 avec la réplique que nous avons
connu il ya encore quelques mois
en europe la situation grecque la mise
en place quand même de 750 milliards sur
la table de solidarité vis-à-vis d'un
pays membre de l'union européenne
susceptible d'être éventuellement
défaillants ne doit pas nous éloigner de
la réalité de l'impact puissants de
cette crise dans les caisses de l'état
et notamment dans les caisses de la
sécurité sociale et nous avons donc ce
double devoir de regarder lucidement la
manière dont nous pouvons à la fois
absorbé ses déficits
et deuxièmement protéger la reprise
économique que nous devons conforter
dans son caractère durable
c'est la raison pour laquelle le choix
du gouvernement qu'il a encore un choix
politique assumé et de ne pas toucher
aux prélèvements obligatoires c'est la
raison pour laquelle là encore dans le
projet de loi de finances le
gouvernement ne vous propose pas
d'augmentation ni de l'impôt sur le
revenu ni l'impôt sur les sociétés ni
l'augmentation de la tva
il n'y a rien dans le plan français
qu'ils soient de nature comparable avec
ce qui est proposé par exemple au
portugal par exemple en espagne où on
baisse les salaires des fonctionnaires
on augmente la tva
je ne parle même pas de la grande
bretagne qui est un sujet qui peut être
un sujet des froids pour vous monsieur
fisher et vos amis qui est un sujet qui
n'a rien à voir avec la position
équilibrée du gouvernement qui vise à
additionner toute une série de mesures
d'économies pour parvenir à atteindre
l'objectif intangible de réduction
niveau déficit à 6% l'année prochaine
4,6 l'année suivante 3 pour
en 2013 c'est à dire de revenir dans un
délai rapide aux niveaux déficit que
nous avions avant la crise et de
poursuivre vers l'objectif qui vise à
atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire
à l'instar de nos amis et voisins
allemands en 2016 tout cela a conduit le
gouvernement à ne pas proposer
d'augmentation quelque nature que ce
soit des prélèvements obligatoires et
dans les prélèvements obligatoires nous
avons à la fois les impôts et nous avons
les éléments de cotisation de nature
sociale et c'est là que se trouve la
problématique de la crds
vous avez rappelé monsieur le rapporteur
vasselle les conditions et la
méthodologie ainsi que le calendrier de
nos travaux avant l'été autour de la
commission de la dette sociale
j'ai d'abord comme ministre du budget a
tenu un engagement que le gouvernement
avait pris devant vous quelques mois
précédemment je crois que nous avons
bien travaillé et il n'est pas
contestable que si nous avions écouté ou
si le gouvernement avait retenu le
consensus
à gauche comme à droite qui s'était
dessinée au sein des travaux de cette
commission de la dette sociale une
augmentation de la crds aurait été
proposé je ne dis pas que c'était le
choix de la facilité car ce serait
irrespectueux vis-à-vis de vous et je ne
dis pas que ce choix n'était pas
respectable dans la logique était la
vôtre mais il est incompatible avec les
choix du gouvernement dans sa cohérence
de politique globale
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement l'a écarté nous avons
écarté
nous avons renoncé à l'augmentation de
la crds chute était évidemment beaucoup
plus simple techniquement et cela nous
aurait évité cher président jégo en
effet une tuyauterie
franchement j'ai vu pire j'ai vu pire et
et si nous avions le temps je pourrai
vous l'expliquer avec beaucoup de
simplicité
au fond c'est assez simple on à 130
milliards à reprendre en termes d'
approche globale le grand mérite au
moins je vous demande de reconnaître du
gouvernement c'est d'avoir une approche
globale à l'intérieur de cette approche
globale nous avons une unité de compte
qui porte sur l'allongement de la durée
de vie de la cades s de quatre années ça
n'est pas un changement de génération je
n'ai jamais lu ni entendu nulle part ni
dans les statistiques de l'insee
ni dans les études démographiques
génération ça faisait quatre ans ou
alors on porte la majorité pénale à
trois ans et là on rentre dans un débat
qui est beaucoup plus lourd donc 2021 à
2025 on change de 4 ans et la reprise de
la dette de crise c'est respectable
deuxièmement des modalités d'application
au tour de financement complémentaire
pour 3 milliards de s'agissant du rabot
ou la suppression de niches fiscales ou
nature sociale entre parenthèses je
m'arrête un instant sur le point de vous
avez évoqué alain vasselle concernant
les sociétés d'assurance entre la mise
en oeuvre opérationnelle des mesures
définies dans le comité d' alerte entre
la réalité de la trésorerie des sociétés
d'assurances les annonces formulées par
certains professionnels de ce secteur
n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité de ce
qu'ils peuvent assumer et nous
considérons au gouvernement qu'il ne
doit pas y avoir de répercussion sur les
tarifs imposés aux sociétaires de ses
contrats d'assurance car les sociétés
d'assurance à l'heure actuelle notamment
de nature mutualiste dans le périmètre
de l'économie sociale ont parfaitement
les moyens d'assumer tout cela j'ajoute
qu'ils bénéficieront encore malgré les
propositions du gouvernement d'un
avantage fiscal par rapport aux secteurs
du privé au moins de la moitié
supplémentaires par rapport à la réalité
des tarifs qui sont proposés donc il y a
de la possibilité d'avancer sur le
chemin sans faire payer aux sociétaires
de ces sociétés mutuelles une
tarification supplémentaire lié à une
décision du gouvernement
troisième élément de nature à offrir une
réflexion globale sur cette question des
130 milliards c'est l'utilisation et la
mobilisation du fonds de réserve des
retraites
et là encore nous sommes cohérents et
nous sommes pertinent donc cette
approche globale elle est importante
elle est logique c'est ce que nous avons
proposé
c'est ce qui a été voté par la haute
assemblée les vertus du débat
parlementaire ont permis de faire
évoluer le texte je dis bien les vertus
de débats parlementaires ont permis de
faire évoluer le texte
ainsi donc la solution gouvernementale
au lieu de porter sur l'affectation des
recettes liées à la suppression de
niches fiscales et sociales à la cades
est directement seront
affectée à la branche la branche famille
il y at il quelque chose de mal à cela
la réponse est non dans la mesure où il
ya le caractère pérenne de la
compensation par la fraction établi
autour de la csg et le gouvernement a
affirmé dans des écrits dans des
positions publiques sa volonté
déterminée de poursuite la réduction et
la suppression des niches fiscales pour
continuer de financer cette politique
nous avons je le rappelle 75 milliards
de niches fiscales 45 milliards de
niches sociales
si la confiance nous est accordée ce sur
quoi nous travaillons aussi en 2012 pour
les grandes échéances nationales
nous poursuivrons indiscutablement cette
politique de réduction de niches
sociales et fiscales
je vous avais écrit je vous remercie
d'ailleurs monsieur vassal ça m'a permis
de faire la une d'un quotidien du soir
dans une incompréhension par des gens
qui par une lecture cursive sont allées
très vite à une conclusion qui ne
correspond pas à l'objectif du
gouvernement puisque justement la
démonstration est faite avec notre débat
sur la cades s et je vous en remercie
et avec notre débat sur le plfss aussi
bien à l'assemblée qu'au sénat que le
gouvernement ne veut pas augmenter les
impôts
que faire de plus que de se retrouver
ensemble autour d'amendements être sous
amendement de la commission des affaires
sociales de la commission des finances
au sein de la majorité comme au sein de
l'opposition pour permettre au
gouvernement de montrer que sa volonté
de ne pas augmenter les impôts
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs messieurs les rapporteurs je
vous remercie de permettre au
gouvernement d'avoir une tribune
supplémentaire pour bien montrer que sa
ligne politique est de ne pas augmenter
les impôts
plusieurs demandes d'explications de
vote monsieur longuet n'est pas madame
la présidente une demande d'explications
de vote mais le souhait d'une courte
suspension de séance de cinq minutes
après les explications de vote et avant
le vote
monsieur cazaux oui le débat que nous
auxquelles nous assistons aujourd'hui
est totalement surréaliste
il ya huit jours j'assistais à la
commission paritaire sur le même sujet
ou se trouvait messieurs va c'est léger
goût et messieurs la scène et j'ai eu je
crois la suppression monsieur la scène
j'en suis sûr
ont voté d'un même et larmes sujet vous
peut-être pas mais monsieur vassal j'en
suis sure it à côté de moi
la proposition du gouvernement proposait
à l'époque par madame montchamp députée
mme montchamp
donc il vous il vous appartenait à ce
moment là c'est là où je ne comprends
pas si vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec ce
système comment aujourd'hui jours après
pouvez vous présenter un autre système
dont kaka qui vaut ce qu'il vaut je ne
le critique pas mais comment pouvez-vous
se trouve votre votre position
totalement surréaliste alors ceci étant
dit monsieur le ministre quand vous
dites tous les gouvernements parlant de
la cad s
tous les gouvernements je crois savoir
autant je me parle de mémoire mais c'est
près de 50 milliards que la cades s à
rembourser ce qui si depuis sa création
mais je crois peu près là mois la moitié
de daniel parle 49 et des poussières
voir monsieur arts puis bien sûr est un
spécialiste il mais il va pas me
chipoter à ce niveau là pour quelques 10
quelques centaines de millions
donc cela caennaise a certainement donc
rembourser une bonne partie sinon plus
de l'antériorité des premières années
alors ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement votre bilan c'est
essentiellement votre bilan qu'elle doit
et dieu sait s'il est lourd on l'a dit
les uns et les autres depuis depuis
trois jours ici et comme vous êtes pris
effectivement par la promesse
présidentielle du ministre eh bien vous
avez proposé donc de faire ainsi pour
permettra de prolonger la cad s de
quatre ans pour permettre d'amortir la
dette et encore ce n'est que la
troisième fois que vous le faites enfin
vos prédécesseurs ça va certainement se
poursuivre par la suite et bien donc en
ce sens cela et bien nous non en ce qui
nous concerne nous n'avons pas assumer
puisque nous les critiques ont depuis
maintenant 2002 nous critiquons 2000
2003 nous critiquons votre gestion nous
voulons pas assumer cela et nous serons
plus tôt si s'il ne tombe pas favorable
car il faut pas toucher c'est vrai le
travail sur des petits et moyens
salaires ça va faire très mal et ça fera
très beaucoup plus mal sur des petits et
moyens salaires ou des petits capitaux
que sur des gros salaires et où de gros
capitaux où on peut compenser d'une
autre manière
donc nous sommes plutôt favorable à la
hausse ou amendements présentés par
monsieur fisher 6e susan anton mme pour
des raisons diverses
eh bien nous ne prendrons pas part au
vote
si la parole est un monsieur fourcade
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je mise
beaucoup admirer le talent avec lequel
vous avez exposé la position du
gouvernement
je me rends hommage l'hommage qui vous
est dû mais je constate que pour
équilibrer les comptes
vous faites quand même fait quand même
appel à des ressources complémentaires
que vous prenez de ci de là dans le
cadre d'un panier en modifiant les
circuits en sorte un peu d'argent de la
caisse d'allocations familiales pour le
remettre à la cadence etc etc
par conséquent votre raisonnement eut
été meilleure si vous aviez dit je
refuse toute augmentation du taux de
lacet de la cad s et je ne prends rien
par ailleurs première helmand deuxième
élément nous avons avec la cad 1 avec la
la crds
le type même d'impôt valable parce qu'il
a une très large assiette et un taux
très faible et que par conséquent le
fait d'augmenter devient uniquement une
question de principe car une
augmentation de 0 26 représentant
quelques dizaines d'euros et encore sur
l'ensemble de l'année et est quelque
chose de très faible et c'est un très
bon impôt
que nous aurions un petit peu développée
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a fait par
ailleurs et pour éviter de simplifier
les circuits géant deuxième argument
le deuxième argument j'allais 3 le
deuxième argument c'est que la cadette a
besoin de crédibilité sur le marché
financier international
je constate moi qui m'occupe des
problèmes de dette endettement que
l'état aujourd'hui on prendre sur les
marchés à un taux x et que la cadette
augmente avec un petit gap
supplémentaire qui est de 0,10 et 0,20
et 0,30 mais jamais le taux auquel
l'état emprunte pourquoi parce que plus
nous compliquons le mécanisme de
financement de la cad s en lui faisant
venir en faisant venir jusqu'à un
certain nombre de taxes est un peu
partout et - lula crédibilise on le fait
d'augmenter la crds qui est le véritable
ressource qui a été créé pour financer
la cades s est un élément qui sur les
marchés et notamment le marché japonais
qui est un marché demandeur d'en prendre
la kadey ce jeu très curieux mais ce
sont les japonais qui à l'heure actuelle
finances la cades est assez largement le
fait d'augmenter légèrement le taux
crédibilisera davantage la cadette et je
pense qu'on pourra arriver avoir une
égalité des conditions d'emprunt sur le
marché entre la caennaise et les
emprunts à moyen et long terme de l'état
enfin troisième troisièmement vous nous
objecter décision de principe que je
salue mais est ce que dans l'ensemble
des documents budgétaires que vous allez
nous présenter la semaine prochaine
il n'y a pas quelques petites
augmentations je pense par exemple à la
redevance télé dont on parle tellement
souvent
la redevance audiovisuelle il me semble
qu'elles vont augmenter un petit peu et
que par conséquent le problème de
principe que vous nous objecter n'est
pas aussi bon que les pas aussi valables
que ce que vous dites et par costil si
ça va augmenter puisque nous avions
décidé vous vous souvenez du
l'augmentation étalée sur plusieurs
années
par conséquent ça va augmenter alors
monsieur le ministre je respecte votre
position de principe mais vous devez
respecter à la position des législateurs
que nous sommes qui souhaite assurer
cette caisse de remboursement de dettes
anciennes
ils ont bien précisé les deux
rapporteurs il s'agit pas je n'aurais
pas le même argument s'il s'agissait de
financer le fonctionnement de la caisse
nationale maladie ou de la caisse
nationale vieillesse là il s'agit de
financer des empreintes d'amortir des
emprunts qui ont été faits sur les
marchés pour financer des dettes
anciennes
il me semble que cette légère
augmentation de la cadence alors on aura
le choix entre le taux proposé par les
rapporte
et les taux proposés par monsieur
barbier le taux de monsieur barbier
étant plus faible
c'est peut-être quelque chose sur lequel
le gouvernement pourrait accepter de
déroger un petit peu à ses principes
mais en ce qui nous concerne
moi je pense que si nous voulons être
sérieux nous devons augmenter
l'alimentation de la cadette merci la
parole et à monsieur lardeux merci merci
mme la présidente monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
moi j'apporte mon soutien à l'amendement
du rapportent des deux rapporteurs et du
président arthuis pour différentes
raisons ou 0 26% de plus ce n'est pas
une augmentation bien considérable dans
l'état actuel des choses cela étant si
nous n'augmentons pas cette annexion
si on avait augmenté l'année dernière
nous ne serions pas dans cette situation
nous augmentons nous proposons 0,26 si
nous faisons pas cette année ça veut
dire qu'en 2012 ou 2013 ou 2014 ce sera
0 50 et puis un point tout simplement
donc plus nous retarderons plus
l'augmentation potentielle sera brutale
et plus l'effet économique que le
gouvernement craint à juste titre sera
dévastateur donc je crois que pour
l'avenir il serait bon de suivre cette
proposition monsieur cazaux a dit tout à
l'heure que c'était le bilan du
gouvernement moi je suis un peu plus
large que lui je crois que c'est le
bilan de 35 années de laisser-aller dans
ce pays ce fait 35 arrêts que nous est
né sont allés à la drogue de la dépense
publique
hélas elle n'a pas est une unité
qualités extraordinaires comme on peut
le voir mais nous sommes encore très
loin de ce que certains dénoncent la
rigueur pour l'instant je ne vois aucune
rigueur dans les propositions qui sont
faites
donc augmenter la crds ensuite un autre
vertu une vertu pédagogique pour
l'instant les français ont vaguement
conscience qu'il ya un déficit mais il
ne le perçoivent pas tant qu'on ne leur
dira pas vous avez dépensé beaucoup plus
qu'on ne pouvait payer
et maintenant il faut rembourser cette
dette contractée
si on leur dit pas ça ils ne
comprendront jamais ils penseront qu'il
ya toujours quelque part une solution
miracle qui leur permettra d'éviter les
pires affres alors monsieur le ministre
avait tout à l'heure que la tuyauterie
que vous proposiez il y avait pire ça je
vous la corde bien volontiers et je
crois que dans le passé notamment
l'origine de la kadey s'il y avait des
tuyauteries peut être encore plus
complexe cela dit la tuyauterie que vous
proposez là quand même un inconvénient
c'est que au moins deux des robinets en
question vont se tarir
très rapidement il y aura plus rien pour
la branche famille son déficit comme je
les dis dans la discussion générale ne
sera pas de 2,7 milliards 6 milliards en
2014 mais de 4 milliards alors je ne
crois pas qu'il soit de bonne politique
qui serait de bonne politique de punir
les familles une fois de plus parce que
je le considère comme cela les familles
sont les grandes victimes de notre
absence de courage en matière de
politique sociale dans ce pays on leur
fait payer
depuis des années la protection sociale
des aînés et on va continuer hélas le
déficit va prendre une tournure tels que
non seulement nous aurons du mal à payer
les prestations familiales et
deuxièmement ensuite leur demander de
payer encore plus en 2013 14 et 15 non
c'est pour ces raisons qu'il serait
raisonnable que la haute assemblée
suivent les propositions des trois
amendements concernés merci la parole
est un monsieur g bout
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je poserai une question un peu
dramatique c'est quand allons-nous
pouvoir réduire ce déficit à quel moment
parce que l'année dernière lors de la
commission des finances
lorsque déjà notre commission des
finances a proposé d'augmenter de 0,15
point la crds
votre collègue d'alors eric woerth nous
a indiqué que ce n'était pas le bon
moment
nous sortions à peine de la crise cette
année
vous l'avez pas fait mais je sais que ça
va se faire à un moment ou un autre nous
opposer la reprise de la croissance qui
ne faut pas casser
l'année prochaine ce sera sans doute le
soutient la croissance
à quel moment pourrons-nous finalement
réduire cette dette et nous serions
coupable de ne pas le faire d'ailleurs
finalement l'année prochaine nous allons
avoir
j'espère une reprise de cette croissance
est en fait nous allons toujours
continué à creuser notre déficit en
matière de de maladies et de vieillesse
pour ce qui est de l'augmentation j'ai
entendu du côté des bancs de du groupe
socialiste dire c'est combien
et ça a été d'ailleurs la modestie de
delà de l'augmentation a été stigmatisée
l'augmentation est parti hier aux appuis
ce que ça représente un effort de 3,4
euros 3,4 euros par mois pour une
personne au smic rémunérés au smic
trois baguettes de pain je pense quand
même que et ce sont pour des dépenses
effectuées
je précise en outre que la la commission
des finances prendra les dispositions
qui permettront de ne pas prendre en
compte dans le calcul du bouclier fiscal
cette augmentation ce qui devrait quand
même satisfaire
sur tous ces bancs l'ensemble de nos
collègues enfin pourrait terminer
monsieur le ministre pour dire que c'est
la deuxième fois que nous transférons de
la csg la première fois et j'avais déjà
en tant que rapporteur au nom de la
commission des finances
parler de la 02 points de csg du fsv
fonds de solidarité vieillesse
puis ensuite j'avais quand même été un
peu en colère de voir les ministres dire
tiens didon cette année l'année dernière
on constate un déficit du fsv et bien
cette année ça va être la même chose et
notre collègue andré lardeux notre nom
oui mais il faudrait peut-être il faut
pas brailler monsieur mais non
mais il faut au moins avoir le courage
de soutenir des mesures courageuses car
nous sommes nous sommes responsables
nous les législateurs il ya l'exécutif
et il ya là les législateurs donc fsv
fsv wind oui bien sûr mais là si nous
laissons faire les 0,28 à la cnaf
eh bien nous allons avoir le même
principe on voit bien quand même
le danger est l'insécurité que
l'amendement montchamp va déclencher
pour les familles il ya véritablement un
danger et je crois monsieur le ministre
que nous sommes dans notre rôle
l'exécutif ne veut pas le faire mais
pourquoi légistatives s'il veut le faire
il a les possibilités de le faire pas
nous ne sommes pas tenus par les parts
parle le dogme finalement l'exécutif je
suis désolé de dire ça fait 25 ans
bientôt que sue parlementaire je trouve
que le parlement est en train de
disparaître sans cela il faut arrêter
donc nous sommes nous prenons nos
responsabilités
moi je n'ai pas envie finalement ensuite
que l'on dise qu'on fait législateurs
des années 90 2000 2010 et bien moi je
veux pas 300 milliards de déficit à la
sécurité sociale
c'est insupportable la parole est à
monsieur vasselle la présence merci je
prends la parole pour
pour deux raisons essentielles la
première c'est bien entendu l'avis
négatif du gouvernement sur cet
amendement
ce qui m'amène à ce stade compte tenu
des enjeux importants qui lie à travers
cet article de la loi
je demanderai à madame la présidente de
bien vouloir réunir la commission des
affaires sociales au moment de la
suspension de séance pour que nous
puissions nous déterminer à savoir si la
commission des affaires sociales dans sa
majorité souhaitent maintenir le moment
où si elle est prête à accéder allemand
de gouvernement pour retirer retirer cet
amendement puisque le gouvernement
demande le retrait
2e deuxième élément de mon intervention
j'ai entendu monsieur cazaux monsieur
cazaux a semble-t-il laissé entendre
qu'ils avaient une certaine incohérence
de ma part à avoir voté lors de la
commission mixte paritaire la
disposition qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale par la voix de la
bande mende marie anne montchamp
prévoyant que le financement de la queue
dès ce doit l'être par des impositions
de toute nature c'est-à-dire de la csg
de la crds et l'amendement que je
propose aujourd'hui selon lui semble
être un peu en contradiction avec la
position que j'ai accepté d'adopter
comme historique farid r je lui dis que
non l'amendement que je dépose et en
parfaite cohérence non seulement avec
les prises de position antérieures mais
également avec la disposition qui a été
intégrée dans la loi organique puisque
l'amendement de marie anne montchamp ne
faisait que conforter la position qui
était la mienne puisque elle considérait
que la moins mauvaise des solutions
c'est est d'augmenter la crds et
certainement pas de faire appel à une
recette extérieur venant de la taxation
des compagnies d'assurance pour
alimenter une caisse dont on savait
comme l'a dit très justement le
président fourcade et comme l'a dit
également jean arthuis était une recette
qui n'était pas pérenne qui n'était pas
dynamique qui fragilisait la cad s et
qui elle pour le coup elle avait pour
risque d'allonger la durée de vie de la
cades s est donc de fait supporter aux
générations futures
le poids de la dette donc c'était
inacceptable pour nous la commission des
affaires sociales a toujours affiché
avec la plus grande netteté qu'elle
était dorénavant opposé
à faire supporter aux générations
futures le poids de la dette que nous
avions constitué nous mêmes pendant le
moment présent et ça a été dit à juste
raison et parle jean arthuis que ça
commençait dans le début des années 90
le ministre a raison de dire que ce
n'est pas quatre années qui constitue
une génération mais 4 à 10 qui s'ajoute
aux autres années ça finit par faire une
génération qui pèse qui pèse donc pour
l'avenir donc il faut bien que nous
mettions un terme à cela c'est pour ça
que l'amendement de waes mad avait été
judicieux puisqu'il disait il n'y aura
plus dorénavant de transfert de dette
sans transfert de recettes pour éviter
justement ne peut faire peser aux
générations futures
malheureusement la crise est passée par
là donc je voulais simplement dire à
notre collègue monsieur cazaux qui avait
aucune incohérence
il y avait une constante de position sur
sur ce sujet je termine pour dire
également amicalement à notre collègue
jean jacques jégou que l' amendement de
marie-anne montchamp n'a pas eu pour
consignes avaient pas automatiquement
pour conséquence de faire appel à la cg
pour financer la connaissent c'est le
gouvernement qui a pris cette solution
le gouvernement a préféré aller
ponctionner la cg de la branche famille
pour financer la cades est ce plutôt que
d'augmenter la crds pour éviter
l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires
mais la conséquence de ça c'est ce qu'a
dit très justement d'autres collègues
andré larbins sait qu on fragilise la
branche famille et de ce point de vue
jean jacques et doux avait raison on a
fragilisé l'année dernière le fonds de
solidarité vieillesse qui ce résultat
qui a aujourd'hui à déficit qui est non
négligeable
et puis demain on risque de retrouver
une situation identique pour la branche
famille puisque son déficit va doubler
du fait justement de l'appel à la csg
donc c'est certainement pas la meilleure
solution que le gouvernement nous
propose ceci j'entends bien que le
gouvernement veuille répondent à
l'engagement très clair du président de
la république qui a dit aux français au
moment de la campagne présidentielle
qu'il était hors de question pour lui
d'augmenter les prélèvements
obligatoires
à la nuance près des remarques
pertinentes faite par le président
fourcade qui laisse à démontrer que dans
la loi de finances c'est peut-être pas
tout à fait conforme pour tous
aux engagements du président de la
république donc nous nous avons notre
devoir d'exprimer devant l'opinion
publique quelle est la voie qui nous
apparaît peut-être pas la plus vertueuse
notre du moins la moins mauvaise moi je
remplis mon rôle de rapporteur général
j'ai une approche technique d' expertise
ensuite il ya un choix politique
le choix politique qui doit être assumée
par la majorité
c'est le président longuet qui les priva
tout à l'heure et par le gouvernement et
moi appartenant à ces deux lots rites et
je ne peux qu'être solidaire de celle ci
même si je considère que les solutions
techniques étaient à retenir mais pas
celles qui nous sont proposées par le
gouvernement
mais celle que je propose ensuite on
prend date on verra bien dans l'avenir
qui aura eu tort et tu aura eu raison et
la parole est un monsieur daudigny merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'instant est solennel et l'issue de
cette discussion sera riche
d'enseignements
si le ton est mesuré en tout cas jusqu'à
maintenant ce débat à mon sens éclairent
d'une lumière violente les
contradictions de fonds qui existe au
sein de la majorité gouvernementale et
ses contradictions ne porte pas sur des
sujets mineurs
elle porte sur une stratégie essentielle
qui est celle de la fiscalité et qui est
celle de la résorption de nous déficits
abyssaux en matière sociale voilà donc
pour les discussions de cet après midi
consacrée au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2011 tout de suite preuve par 3 emmanuel
kessler reçoit patrick devedjian le
ministre en charge du plan de relance
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire également les
journaux de 19h et de 22h et bien sûr
toujours notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne